[Music]
in anything for my girl news anything
for my girl
anything anything Geo anything anything
tell me uh Tess [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me
what do I want give me something Peggy
will he let you Peggy oh yeah yeah what
is that
Oh strap-on and [ __ ] me out they
can't do that well would you let her
I'll use a little dick Paul wasn't so
sure I would it has this natural clothes
reflect ride to like just test it to see
I'll be taking a shower she's like let
me try to poke your but I'm like you can
try but it does natural clothes reflex
yeah have your tights are praising him
no it's impossible this bubbles like
yeah like his eyes like Joe's eyes my
present defense is crazy good yes from
being in the military is it it's like Oh
your butt's always awake oh yeah yeah it
doesn't one eye open yeah I feel like
every girl has done that try to put
their boyfriends a black hole just to
freak him out why you guys are evil I'm
doing the human man keep like he's you
know what zas looks like you said oh I
got to see it and because I've been
bringing it up so much in videos yeah
finally finally like I'm like let me see
he's like why you don't need to like
just to say that I have just insanely
update he let me see his but yeah he was
lock her in the closet
and then
Oh make you feel like I saw a whole new
never showered together no but nobody
talks together but I try was facing me
he was show you Hitler when you shower
no one cell affects you never like clean
up after sex you see walking away with
his clothes on during sex yes that's
wise he has a onesie any he has a sex
once dude that would be typo some free
it's like that final suit from [ __ ]
black mirror and [ __ ] yeah so you've
never seen your husband's but now I have
yeah wow that's incredible yeah I didn't
really realize it until we were on JK
news and I was like I've never seen
I almost got away with it I need to see
the whole body before anything happens
Oh shower then he's always like we've
been teasing you every time you go
inside he's like I'm like this and we're
like he's standing behind me like even
like by going in and getting out of the
shower and you always have to like like
he's playing deep I never dropped the
soap I never I could maybe I didn't look
maybe I wasn't paying attention cuz I
was like you know we're making out and
kissing and stuff but I didn't really I
wasn't really looking and he's a tall
guy it's hard not to miss his butt
exactly it's like face level exactly Wow
the elusive Steve green but yeah I only
saw it congratulations oh yeah we
haven't gone tinted bye
by a Bey's world a rich Chinese kid is
facing prison after recklessly spending
36 million dollars on his girlfriend see
miss like that saying I'm so jealous
how do you spend jealous wha how do you
spend 36 we could do it easy
I got a real estate agent I got yeah
bond don't want some [ __ ] Netflix
article would with the I mean Netflix
the next shark movie I would buy an
island filler with kittens I would do
technically hmm
it's do a lot of money but technically
it's 11 million the conversion
no no what happened was he loaned 11
million he spent all that on her but he
tried to make the money back through
gambling all day long and then so he
racked up more and total was 36 million
it was ten point five million that he
took from his father's company oh yes I
gave it to another company [ __ ]
figures that's a lot of money away
couple cats [ __ ] yes I was my castle so
he borrowed money from his wealthy
friends which added up to twenty five
point four million and then he gambled
away because he gambled in the net
that's what ended up happening the total
money that he lost was twenty five point
four million how do you spend that much
money I mean I can't show you gambling
cuz gambling is like whatever you want
to do but on things like I can't even
think of what to buy if it's not real
estate or something big like a yacht or
whatever like what are you doing for Kim
Kardashian's birthday Kanye bought her
like what is it investments or whatever
like two million dollars in a deist
thoughts or whatever two million dollars
in adidas four million dollars and this
and that that's easy you do that but do
you think he's spending it on stock oh I
can't I took a trip to Dubai and
likewise gotta be like even a hundred
thousand or whatever I mean like they
went to Macau together and she was like
egging him on to continue to gamble the
money and like she just kept
apparently like he were just blaming it
on her that's his
and fault thank you would just bite her
all this like luxurious stuff like
luxury brand stuff this is the girl
she's like model okay yo her [ __ ] must
be bomb jewelry and designer or it looks
like an avatar yeah she's like a fake
person that's crazy right jewelry and
designer hard things that could be that
could be probably tape blogging um this
whole situation here goals yeah really
yeah [ __ ] goals right there dude [ __ ]
yeah I do think it if it guy to spend
the 11 Holly I mean yeah goals
mmm-hmm it's not my fault you spent the
money he's dumb as [ __ ]
exactly I'm not holding a gun so you'd
be like you'll buy me a [ __ ] house
[ __ ] you just holding your [ __ ] to his
head that's like a gun gene I do that
and there's no she's pretty killer fish
it is pretty killer you think David
[ __ ]
oh yeah what's a lot probably you think
bunny makes her horny probably yeah yeah
probably cuz I don't think I'd see Oprah
and be like Oh bill you're number get
hard even though I got a really pretend
that she's someone else come on we're
gonna do this slap in your dick yeah
biologically or I don't know who's
biologically or societally I'm sure
someone in the comments will correct me
but that girls are like women in society
value like beauty and stuff I guess men
look for beauty more and women and and
youth and for guys women look for like
security well long term yeah like that
kind of stuff so it would be harder for
you to like be attracted to money in
Oprah you know yeah yeah spread your see
under human nature dude is like it's
like or it's almost animalistic to like
the [ __ ] peacocks they have to show
the prettiest [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
yeah and what and the females are
attracted to that and it would make
sense that a guy would be attracted to
whoever's like the most fertile
you know which is typically younger
females mm-hmm
that's crazy how long were they together
apparently it was two years yeah I
wasn't super job and so like he was
finally arrested because his friends
never got the money back I had a girl
take me to salute soup plantation and
use a two-for-one coupon and she paid
for it and I was being [ __ ] pampered
thank you did you get horny I know but I
felt taking care of lady I know I know
I'm all time I think he's in the
billions no I'm not sure billionaire
yeah he said everyone knows him
everything one of you guys know who he
is but even you guys but he really is so
crazy stupid rich but when we went to go
eat he still used coupons when we went
to go eat yeah coupons I'm like well we
had a celebrity stop by barbell whoa geo
tell me about that uh to to train but
then he ended up having one of the our
co-workers pay for his day pass which is
like 20 bucks
what oh and this is someone we all know
too they might have they might have been
like kind of down and out at that moment
you know like that's true because just
because you make a lot doesn't mean you
spend well either like you know how to
manage your money like there's a lot of
people that [ __ ] make a [ __ ] ton of
money and then they just blow it or
whatever they just assume that that
they're gonna get free [ __ ] well you
just never know their situation you know
what are youtubers single or maybe he
didn't carry cash on him or whatever I
don't know man there's always different
reasons for that [ __ ] but it is it is
funny when someone has outrageous
amounts of money and they're like still
focused on $2 discounts or whatever yeah
that's so funny how was that interaction
there we just bust out the coupons
that's all I tried not to show it cuz we
all went out to eat as a group right and
then would he bust out the coupons he
said I have been saving these since I
got these in the mail I'm just like huh
interesting you still open mail yeah you
know it's pretty fun though that I used
to do is remember when Vegas was hella
cops like you get a [ __ ] tuna free [ __ ]
if you go here
go there collect that this gift bag or
like $2 shrimp cocktail or whatever I
used to do comp tours because it was so
fun like me my friends would just go out
and like look for [ __ ] and then look for
deals and then spend a day that way I
mean you get into like some weird
casinos that you would never walk into
and go to like down there like in your
20s and probably broke yeah but I miss
doing that and I'll do it again at least
for me me and you we got any event so
we're like oh yeah yeah Tiffany I went
to a [ __ ] event one at once and they
never gave us a free stuff and we left
pissed and we we deleted all everything
that we post if I'm like [ __ ] you you're
not gonna give me my swag back here it's
a [ __ ] like oh you [ __ ] about your
brand oh yeah
wait don't well maybe maybe well
whatever we're not here because like
we'd like you like whatever we're here
because you want our swag bag right join
was good yeah
tell me to you okay well listen to the
DiGiorno conversation or you think ah no
it wasn't a second get why you guys
would do it cuz they're calling you out
because they want obviously free
exposure without paying you guys and the
empire that you guys have built right so
I can see what you guys would be pissed
cuz it's like oh you're just trying to
use me what the [ __ ] sound good so again
it was a big family known brand to like
everybody's gonna drop any [ __ ] names
but you know what it's bad on them
because they're the ones that are
running the company and creating this
kind of perception through the
influencers that's their fault yeah
their snacks weren't even good I was
cheesy jicama all I want to know is how
do you find someone that will blow 11 to
30 million on exactly how do you find
someone
whose [ __ ] do I have to have on my chest
to do that tattoo like my [ __ ] like put
my [ __ ] on you but then he literally
meant [ __ ] yeah
make sure to watch it you have to do
that like Pauly
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]